i think everybody wondering here tonight
tyler glass now how many innings is he
going to be able to give the rage you'd
like to see him efficient two guys
especially here with tyler tonight to
just be sharp sharp at the breaking ball
good command of the heater and a cut in
the mids he swings through a 98 mile per
hour fastball to get this one started
and a cut in the miss a hundred
a hundo here early
on the strikeout full count freeman off
with the pitch
and a cut and a miss he strikes him out
on the
curveball three strikeout to the inning
you wonder what kind of confidence mike
voltanovich has 21 starts a year ago 8-6
with a 454 era well if you want to put
those questions to bed go out and pitch
a good game without it
91 and that ball is hit in the air to
shallow right center and in comes ronald
lacuna junior who looks skyward two
balls two strikes
on the ground slowly hit toward dansby
there's one and the turn is in plenty of
time just what mike fultonevich needed a
double play we're scoreless after one
dansky swanson coming off a career night
against the mets last night five runs
batted in
and stroke to center field keermeyer
drifting back to the wall that ball is
gone straight away center homer for hot
hitting dansby swanson and the braves
strike first in the second stay hot kid
and there's that
pitch he got him a cut in the miss
o'reilly a strikeout victim better goes
a swing at a miss and turns out on
strikes
i don't know if we'll see him this year
the pitch
and he waved at a slider mike's getting
the corners now and that's his second
strikeout two out spaces empty one
nothing atlanta and now here's mike
zanino 3-2 pitch breaking ball lifting
in the air to left center field back on
it is ozuna to the wall and this one is
going to carry into the seats
mike zanino with a solo home run and he
ties the game at one
here in the third
two balls two strikes
and a swing and a miss mike don't forget
the rosin bag mike turns the glass down
he starts the fourth
the 2-2 swing and a miss
he struck him out as ozuna goes down
swinging for the second time today
oh strike three call what a dandy of a
breaking ball right there
oh straight call
that curveball just buckled him out the
side so back-to-back walks here's hunter
renfrow swinging in a high fly ball left
center field this is going to drive in
see aren't they back he's looking up
into the rings he lost sight of the ball
because it's in the seats
hunter renfro who had 33 home runs a
season ago barrels went up for the first
time as a ray it's a three-run home run
and the rays now lead 4-1 the ball makes
a different noise when he makes
contact and that was everything there it
was loud and then it got small and
here's a drive to right field by joey
wendell to the wall and it is gone
joey wendell has gone back to back with
hunter rethrow the rays now lead it five
to one
back to back in
belly to belly moving into second base
is adama's
ground ball left side wide open and it's
going to be knocked down but here comes
adamus he's going to score
no chance to make a play on him
and adamus scores
that run
charged to fulton and it's 6-1 now
brandon lau he started the inning high
fly ball center field
ciarte drifting to the track in front of
the wall and that's going to be over his
head off the wall
one round is scored kiermeier has
crouched the plate zenino scores and all
the way to third
goes brandon lau the rays plate two more
runs to make it eight to one
into the dirt this one bounces away and
down the line from third comes loud with
another run and lau has scored
another rinfrow unloaded his first home
run in a raised uniform here's another
one deep towards the left center field
and ciarte turns and looks gone
a line drive home run by hunter renfro
and the rays have reached double digits
they lead 10-1
barrel enough a couple of them here
tonight
that one again had that sound oh it was
a laser
so far
their defense has
hurt him freddie goes the other way and
dumps that in for a base hit acuna
is around third he is headed for the
plate and the throw bounces off his
helmet he gets away from zunino beaks
backs up and the braves are on the board
freddie freeman with a base hit to left
field
ten to two raise adams stays in there to
d.h
swinging a drive that's hammered toward
left field that ball is pretty well hit
that ball is gone matt adams has hit a
three run homer
lefty lefty and the braves come roaring
back
it's now a 10 to five game
with two outs joy joy's at third and lau
is at second
liner into center that's going to fall
base hit here comes choi he will score
lyle crosses the plate
driving in two for jose martinez and the
rays now have a dozen
but boy when he's healthy what a great
piece of the puzzle
where was he third or fourth in rookie
of the year voting a couple years ago
here's adamus up the left-field line
that's going to be fair back to the
corner
wendell's going to score it'll be a
double for adamus and the rays had
another run
[Applause]
oh a long one back into left field
duvall will go to the wall and watch it
sail that baby is gone
jose martinez unloads his first home run
to the ray's uniform
rays
make it a 14-5 game and jose alvarado
goes to the mound
wave and a miss that's a team record for
the rays they've recorded 19 strikeouts
tonight got to get to 20.
got to do it right here
climb all into center field cutting
across margot
he's going to make that grab
and the reigns are winners 14 to 5.